neutrophils constitute majority of the  circulating leukocytes they are much  more numerous than eosinophils basophils  or the muscles the entire cytoplasm of  neutrophils are filled with cytotoxic  granules  neutrophils are generated from the bone  marrow myeloid progenitor cells from the  myeloid progenitors immature neutrophils  are secreted into the bloodstream from  there they can enter the tissue space  neutrophil invasion is a hallmark of  acute inflammation whenever there is an  inflammation neutrophil squeeze its way  out into the tissue and there they can  encounter pathogens especially they  encounter bacteria  neutrophil increase is a hallmark for  bacterial infection and they engulf the  bacteria and phagocytosis them  so once the bacteria is taken up it  would be fused with lysosome and it  would be degraded also neutrophil can  kill the bacteria by using reactive  oxygen species